[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
March 23rd I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
as many expected the Federal Reserve
raised interest rates by a quarter
percentage point yesterday and while
that rate move was among the smaller
increases the FED has approved over the
past year it comes as the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank has sent Jitters
through the banking sector so what does
it all mean for everyday consumers like
you and me the wsj personal finance
team's Oyen adidoyan has been talking to
financial professionals about that and
she joins me now hey Oyen thanks for
being with us thanks for having me so
Oyen the FED raised interest rates by a
quarter percentage point yesterday as
simply as you can what does that
actually mean so that means that for us
things like mortgages credit cards and
auto loans are going to be a little bit
more expensive it's the fed's effort to
encourage people to spend less and
borrow less so credit card debt's going
to be even more expensive to maintain
but things like savings accounts
high-yield savings accounts are going to
be a little bit more lucrative so what
does that mean higher credit score
requirements or more stringent credit
checks it's hard to say for sure but
that's what I've been hearing from
Financial analysts the director of
research at Alexandria Capital tells me
that things like getting a car loan a
mortgage or a small business loan are
going to be a lot harder for individuals
Goldman Sachs even says that tougher
standards will be equivalent to a
quarter or half Point increase in The
fed's Benchmark rate I also spoke to
Timothy Chubb who's the chief investment
officer at Gerard a wealth management
firm and he says that banks are
definitely going to be a little bit more
conservative when it comes to how much
they're lending out and who they're
lending to all right so getting a loan
could be more of a challenge so let's
talk about how people can get ahead of
this how can they get their personal
finances in order to increase their
chances of eventually getting a loan
financial advisors say that people
should
shop around different rates people
should really focus on paying down any
High interest debt that they have such
as credit cards first njr here's where
High interest rates are actually a good
thing because these raids can give
Savers several ways to earn more money
on their cash accounts
interest rates on certificates of
deposit for example are the highest
they've been in a decade Americans can
now earn over five percent from a
variety of banks
I recently wrote about CDs which
typically require a 6 or 12 month time
commitment but cash input has
skyrocketed from 36.5 billion in April
of last year to 418 billion in January
according to the Fed so interest rates
actually have a friendly side to them
yeah especially for Savers all right now
you know a moment ago you mentioned
credit card debt nobody likes to see a
mountain of debt sometimes they even
have it on multiple cards and paying it
down that could be kind of an
intimidating process
yeah it's a numbers game that can really
weigh down
payments the average annual percent rate
on new credit card offers this month is
23.65 percent that's the highest it's
been in decades the average APR on
credit card accounts with balances being
carried over from month to month is
20.40 according to the Federal Reserve
and that's the highest it's been since
1994. and think about this someone with
five thousand dollars in debt on a card
with a 23.65 APR and a 250 monthly
payment will pay about one thousand two
hundred and seventy seven dollars in
interest and that'll take 26 months to
pay off that balance according to
Discover credit cards payment calculator
that's like money going out the window
yeah exactly and you know Jr those with
less than Stellar credit or shorter
credit histories will be affected the
most by these Titan lending standards
and so Financial analysts recommend
really paying down these debts by using
larger down payments on any loans when
possible to boost your chance of
approval and oh yeah these percentages
these these interest rates are 23 20
this is just vicious for people who are
trying to hold on to their money yeah
and and you know what I spoke to Matt
Schultz who is the chief credit Analyst
at Lending Tree and he basically said
that the damage has already been done
for those with credit card debt and
regardless of whatever the FED decides
to do next credit card debt interest is
still catching up to the rate increases
that we've already seen in the last year
so it's going to get a little bit more
expensive in the near future to have
debt now the quarter point rate increase
is among the smaller increases the FED
has implemented over the past year and
fed chairman Jerome Powell said that the
FED could very likely raise them several
more times as the year goes on so let's
talk about what that means for consumers
going forward so that means that for
consumers these increases in rates are
not something that is going to go away
anytime soon and so mortgage rates auto
loans and credit card our debt is going
to continue to get a little bit more
expensive until the FED feels like they
can get inflation under control so what
steps can people take to climb out from
under what in many cases is a mountain
of debt I mean financial advisors say
it's not going to be easy but those
saddled with high credit card balances
should consider a balance transfer or a
low interest personal loan also they
recommend that people should try to
reduce their credit card debt to below
50 percent of your available credit
consider paying your bills on time and
cleaning up any issues if possible on
your credit report financial advisors
recommend shopping around as well for
the best rates and terms and building a
relationship with your bank this also
includes making sure you check your
credit score as frequently as you can to
track your progress so analysts tell me
that for consumers going forward it's
definitely going to be a rocky road in
the next few months as the FED tries to
curb inflation so these things that
we've been talking about mortgage rates
auto loans credit card debt are going to
continue to get expensive until the FED
feels like they have the economy under
control given tighter credit and still
Rising interest rates analysts warn
consumers to play it safe and kind of
limit these Grand expenses
um for example if you're planning on
taking a big vacation the next couple
months maybe consider something more
local think carefully before you're
taking on any new loans and really focus
on paying down high interest debt such
as credit cards first at the same time
it also makes sense to take advantage of
these increased interests that you can
get on savings accounts with better
returns like high yield savings accounts
certificates of deposits and treasuries
ah there's that friendly side of the
interest rates exactly all right that's
the Wall Street Journal personal finance
teams oganoyan ogan thanks so much for
being with us thanks for having me and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign